we have a voicemail number which is 2192
davidp
here's a caller who is not in favor of
joe biden
listen to what he has to say yeah i'm
watching here for the first time and
uh i just want you to know that
you call yourself well i'm looking at
free speech tv
killed by the lucky cousin
of the united states you'll be lucky to
be
free speech tv
i want you to think about that
he is pretty much he is pretty much to
the left wing of that
party which is not even a party anymore
it's radical extremist leftist
thanks pacman yeah listen um
biden's not the authoritarian it's trump
who's been hostile to a free press it's
trump who's been hostile to media it's
trump who's kicked people out of the
press briefing room
it's trump who calls media fake news and
the enemy of the people
joe biden you can say a lot of negative
things about joe biden
and we've said many of them joe biden is
not an authoritarian
joe biden clearly much like barack obama
respects and understands the role of a
free and independent press
and this is how things go backwards
trump is one of the most authoritarian
and hostile to media presidents we've
had in a long time
and people are calling me saying media
and free speech are in trouble
if biden wins come on guys you're living
in a fantasy world
on today's bonus show i am going to tell
the story
of firefighters visiting my house at 4
00 am
this weekend okay why were they at my
house at 4am this weekend
i'll tell you on the bonus show make
sure to sign up at joinpakman.com or by
becoming a patron
at patreon.com david pakman show